les habitants de notre dame des landes
connaîtront-ils un jour cette scène un
avion de ligne qui survolent leur
clocher avant d'atterrir c'est quasi
certain
mais contrairement aux ambitions dantès
du début des années 90 d'en faire un
outil international est une plateforme
grant west le projet apparaît désormais
à nuancer ce qui est clair d'abord c'est
qu'avec l'agrandissement de roissy n'en
a perdu pour l'instant peut être plus
que chartres un appui éventuel de l'état
et donc une dimension internationale
ensuite à côté de ça l'augmentation
régulière du trafic de nantes atlantique
fait que sa construction devient
inéluctable après 2005 mais avec dans
l'immédiat le seul caractère régional
nous avons une aérogare qui est
perpendiculaire à la piste donc nous
sommes on plaint donc n'ont pratiquement
peu plus agrandi soissons ça serait
uniquement à un agrandissement des
aérogares mais pas les pistes à les
pistes ça c'est impossible
les pistes on à la voie ferrée d'un côté
on a lac de grand lieu de l'autre les
salaires la commune de saint-aignan donc
on ne peut plus s'agrandir
seulement voilà doute irait bien si ce
projet qui affiche bientôt 20 ans avait
continué dans les mêmes termes qu'au
départ un projet interrégional
d'aménagement commun du grand ouest que
les conseils généraux de
loire-atlantique et d'ille-et-vilaine
appelait alors de leurs voeux pierre
méhaignerie et luc de joie était
tellement en phase à l'époque qu'ils
avaient même lancé ensemble l'étude de
faisabilité du projet or aujourd'hui
seuls le conseil général de loire
atlantique a continué et des centaines
d'hectares ont été acquises sur la
commune de notre dame des landes faut
entre 1000 et 12 cents hectares pour
arriver à construire totalement
l'aéroport et aujourd'hui nous
approchons en propriété des 900 hectares
par conséquent ça ne sera pas
l'acquisition des terrains qui créera un
problème quelconque à mon sens est
d'ailleurs c'est notre gros avantage
d'avoir su anticiper depuis beaucoup
d'années anticipée ou précédé pour
rendre irréversible si personne ne
conteste que nantes soit aujourd'hui le
pôle numéro 1 de l'ouest rennes ne fait
que du trafic d'affaires
en revanche la dimension internationale
du futur aéroport laisse perplexe je ne
crois pas aux ambitions internationales
de notre dame
landes l'expérience a déjà prouvé que
des essais de développement de lignes au
départ de nantes vers l'amérique du nord
ont connu des échecs retentissants
finalement c'est moi la proximité du
futur aéroport avec nantes qui critique
et que de sentiments breton d'investir
chez les autres sans contrepartie notre
dame des landes se fera mais au donnant
donnant
[Musique]